hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
[Music]
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons welcome
to the Tim Dylan show I'm here with
Devon Kosta stop them we are on the
porch so you're all [ __ ] happy now I
know we're not at the board everybody
gets angry we just saw a clip of
Sebastian Maniscalco hosting the VMAs
the Video Music Awards on MTV yeah and
that is an unwinnable impossible it's an
impossible position for comedian to be
in Sebastian's amazing is one of the
best comedians doing it right now he
sold out the garden he's got like an
attendance record it's amazing the guy's
amazing but it's rough and he even said
he was on like CBS the morning show or
would ever go and this is not my demo
yeah you saying he's nervous yeah he's
like I'm nervous it's not my demo and so
he's a little bit of a rough yeah it's a
little rough he does a few jokes about
people being triggered and they don't
like him he's not he's you know he's an
older guy yeah they don't want a
comedian in there now these people their
15 year old kids they wanted a comedian
would have been like Pete Davidson
that's the guy right somebody young
would ever you know it was a weird
choice yeah it was like Bobby Kelly
hosts the MTV Music Awards you know the
minute he starts Bobby starts cursing up
yeah [ __ ] you okay hey did anybody else
hear fat anyway I love Bobby but I would
have bombed everyone it would have been
bad yeah would not have been good and
it's a bit shouldn't survive but it was
like oh you know you can almost see like
the minute where I almost wished as a
comic he had just gotten real
confrontational yeah I've been like hey
you know
why oh you don't want to laugh how about
[ __ ] this how about I got paid
already
and I don't give a [ __ ] if you laugh
okay yeah oh and then just started going
going good people are smirking in the
crowd Queen Latifah why don't you wipe
that gorilla grin off your face [ __ ]
Queen Latifah okay you're so happy what
did you get a high score of
freecreditreport.com what's going on hey
cardi B does that stand for hepatitis B
you're a dirty [ __ ] I already got paid
folks I don't give a [ __ ] hey Shawn
Mendes is here we know you're gay okay
you keep hiding it are you embarrassed
you smoked more bone than a Texas
pitmaster just come out with it
hey Liz Loza in the backstage putting
her diabetic boots on get ready to
perform for everybody okay I know it's
so empowering she's hooked up it's not
that empowering what she's hooked up to
five sleep apnea machines so she doesn't
die in the middle of the night okay I
walked through a cloud of smoke my mom's
cooking zucchini back there it's a good
[ __ ] joke that's what he opened with
didn't get much yeah I would just love
if you just went after him went Adam me
ghost is here what the [ __ ] is that that
sounds like something I order in the
restaurant that I'm embarrassed my wife
took me to you know what I mean she
always wants to go to these cultural
ethnic spots have you been to these
places I would love it if you just went
[ __ ] hard yeah if it's totally
off-brand just totally right at them
you know it would have been great would
have been super memorable it would have
been absolutely hey Billy Ray Cyrus's
here have your daughter's at pansexual
bipolar schizophrenic [ __ ] how about
that give it up for raising that MK
ULTRA victim when did you turn her over
to the government three Jesus
is she even sexy what is she doing she's
humping the floor it's like she's got an
autoimmune disease are you embarrassed
will Naz X is here your hey it's a
reverse situation the black guy's
dragging the white guy's corpse around
give it up for Billy Ray Cyrus you
one-hit wonder you're living off your
daughter and this black gay guy alright
anyway let's get this show started you
want to beat red good yeah that would
have been a better show I would have
rather that to ever happen it would have
been the greatest thing in the history
of entertainment had he just gone out
and torched the entire room and refused
to get off stage what if he refused to
get off stage no I'm not done you could
go to commercial and when you come back
I'll be standing right [ __ ] here
but not just hatred that he's bobbing
like it's racist agendas he just goes
out you know he just starts going in it
because that's what happens people don't
realize like is Michael Richards erases
probably but what that was really about
is a guy who had been pushed to his wits
and yeah and sometimes you feel that way
when you're bombing it is the horrible
feeling or when you're not doing well
and you just want to lash out at people
you say the worst thing and say the
worst things possible to them to make
them because they're ready not laughing
right she was like let's make them upset
you know something let's get him to feel
something you know yeah I mean I would
love to see that great comedian guys
amazing weird gig that's a challenging
gig
I just called Andrew Schultz I was like
what do you do in that situation so it
was like maybe musical comedy works
that's where you bring out the Jimmy
Fallon dumb [ __ ] right and you sing what
Miss Piggy I will set off you're a fan
of this podcast and you listen to it I
predicted the future i sat on the
podcast last week there will just be a
shaking ass that will just be what music
is like wah and Liz oh who is insanely
talented but performed in front of just
a big bulbous ass yeah that shook in the
background but literally had been a week
after he said that wild chance I mean
it's like we're manifesting ya [ __ ] on
the show it's back to school I said I
was gonna do this episode for a very
long time this is an episode that is for
children high school kids kids in
college maybe it applies to everybody
the rules and the laws of popularity are
what's the word I'm looking for here
they apply to everybody uh-huh Universal
correct thank you
they are universal Oh what you never
[ __ ] stumbled on a word you never
[ __ ] ever you can't even speak have
for you in this room got a 75 IQ should
I have used Ebonics yeah hey maybe a
little Ebonics yo yo yo yo it's gonna be
so hard to not do that for the whole
episode we're gonna try but I'm really
not making any promises yeah it's hard
to see something like that talk about
anything comic I'm like man it's a rough
gig and man I wish you went Adam which
you can't do but it would just be fun
yeah you know yeah the laws of
popularity are universal that being said
I've said it before if you're a loser in
high school you will be a loser for the
rest of your life even if you have lots
of money and you succeed in profession
you are going to internalize that in
your entire life you'll be a loser and
I'm out here in LA I meet these people
that are very successful very rich and
I've never fully like made peace with
that period in their lives it's an
incredibly important period in your life
and if you throw it away and you learn
the
wrong lessons from it which most people
do and I don't mean listen if you're
like somebody who's trans and getting
beaten up every day I'm not saying it's
your fault I'm saying that this advice
is for people that are you know
comfortable with themselves to the
extent that they can play the game in a
social arena if you are cutting yourself
if you are throwing up every day if you
are a drug addict if your parents are
molesting you if you're living in a car
I get it
I don't need the messages in the emails
of who was always supposed to be popular
when my dad was [ __ ] me I don't know
[ __ ] better but really I don't need
throw your back into it
but if it's happening anyway nothing not
doing a good job never makes sense no
matter what job you're doing and for who
right point being I don't need the
emails I understand that there's a lot
of people out there they're dealing with
more important [ __ ] than being popular
so they think but that's not the case
everybody you know what time it is baby
you know what time it is it's time to
talk about [ __ ] it's that time I'm a
party comic and we're gonna have a party
we're party and that's what we're about
fun in the Sun Cancun
Mali GHB corona with lime [ __ ] in a
pool [ __ ] on the beach [ __ ] in
your penthouse apartment
[ __ ] that's what this shows about
what I'm about okay
that's where you pump that iron that's
why I'm Aikido kid I'm just doing Kido I
don't give a [ __ ] I haven't had a carb
in three days I punched a woman in the
face today I will get strong enough to
start punching men will start with women
and that's what it is I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm training I'm tough I'm a
professional fighter three days on keto
I have the heart of a lion I am a world
champion heavyweight world champion many
of you want our Kido and I wouldn't say
anything negative about you other than I
I mean it's just like you're not men
that's all you're not men you're not a
male there's nothing wrong with that
your big sloppy carb Laden vag so for
those who who aren't on keto who aren't
tough who aren't cool maybe you need a
little blue shoe to keep that dick hard
my dicks are 24 hours a day a
[ __ ] every single day I open
rubric our doors with it okay
some of you don't have that because
you're not tough you're not eating meat
meat you're not eating eggs whole eggs
get that yolk in there protein many of
you aren't doing that you're eating
spike you're eating pasta pasta I'm a
baby eat a [ __ ] steak that you cook
outside you hear it sizzles that's a
piece of meat being cooked in a pan
outside by a lake like a [ __ ] man for
those of you who aren't a man you know
what you need and there's nothing wrong
with this a little blue chew it's got
the same active ingredients as Viagra
and Cialis except it's in a chewable
form you do not have to go to the doctor
it's an easy online consultation quick
and easy blue choose doctors will be
able to prescribe you their pills online
very easy they ship them to your house
and discreet packaging ok blue [ __ ]
shoe ok
you take them you stay hard you [ __ ]
that [ __ ] ok you don't learn her name
you don't take her out to eat you don't
do any of that [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] man
you're the leader of the Wolfpack you're
the alpha dog you don't talk to that
[ __ ] you don't even know that [ __ ]
after you not understand and if it's a
dude you [ __ ] that twink you don't ask
him his name doesn't matter
[ __ ] that twink and you throw them in
the street see get out of your twink I
don't need you I'm a [ __ ] man all I
need is my me
eat my [ __ ] and then the meat that I eat
Kido
you're just sweating all day just sweat
sweat that [ __ ] out okay if you're out
on a date with somebody and they order
maybe a carbohydrate or they order
something with sugar pity that weak
[ __ ] understand gotta get that blue
true that chewable dick pill keeps you
nice and hard hard like a rocket you
could just [ __ ] all night boom boom boom
[ __ ] foreplay does it matter [ __ ] if
she's getting off it's about you you got
a knot don't be doing on any anything
else foreplay
stop it don't put your fingers anywhere
your fingers are for tearing apart meat
putting it in your mouth just [ __ ] you
don't kiss you know kiss nobody you
don't even look at them you make them
face the [ __ ] wall okay boom pow pow
pow pow pow pow pow violent nasty
[ __ ]
on a dirty mattress rent an apartment to
[ __ ] don't even do in your own home rent
the dirty mattress in an apartment to
just [ __ ] and have no air conditioning
dirty sweaty [ __ ] above a grocery
store
hopefully it's getting robbed right as
your [ __ ] you hear gunshots piercing
people's flesh as you're coming that's
the best try to get an apartment in a
bad area flophouse so you could [ __ ]
while other people get murdered blue
true calm what's the promo code t d TD
free shipping nope you pay five dollars
shipping five dollars first order free
first order is free how [ __ ] good is
that folks have no reason not to get
this first order is free and you know
the way it is you know I'm kidding but
you know we're all in our Yaman in my
mid-30s sometimes your dick just doesn't
want to play the game you dick just
doesn't want to play the game but that's
okay because you got a secret weapon you
got that blue chew you know you got that
blue chew promo code TD
five dollars shipping they'll give you
your first order free if it works keep
using it if it doesn't who cares doesn't
matter you know you're a [ __ ] man you
got a dick nice and hard keep that dick
hard okay maybe you don't have a sexual
partner you just want a hard dick that's
cool too you just walk around a gym with
that big hard dick let everybody know
you're a [ __ ] King okay what were you
like in school because I'm gonna go into
my story a fat kid that was kind of
viciously mean and funny so I didn't
really get much [ __ ] yes and that's an
important archetype of person to be yeah
the fat vicious kid kid who's always on
the verge of tears
always on the verge of a total full
breakdown yep and just attacking I've
been this person for a decade attacking
left and right right just shredding
people before they can shred you
preemptive war yeah
fight them there so we don't have to
fight them here yeah yes that's an
important [ __ ] person to be schools
need those those [ __ ] keep you on
your toes
cuz they have nothing to lose they go
home they jerk off they are sad they eat
disgusting food they look at themselves
and they want to die and that's the
[ __ ] that comes in then go check that
camera make sure it's not [ __ ] around
that's the person who comes in and
really [ __ ] gives it to you yeah he
keeps everybody on their toes even the
popular kids will kind of keep him
around yeah because usually he's a
little more clever than they are he's a
little bit more he can kind of roll with
the punches a little bit yeah and they
know that he's not a threat to them he's
not [ __ ] their checks right he's not
cooler than them he's not catching the
past they should on the field whatever
okay interesting when I started school I
was like in my shell didn't talk to
anyone was still doing drugs still had
friends from my hometown didn't care it
didn't want to participate in Catholic
high school thought it was a waste of
time I'm hanging out with crackheads in
a crack house who gives a [ __ ] about
in your backyard and whatever I don't
care about your sports team it was a
little defense mechanism right you know
and I sat alone in ninth grade with the
other table of kids and we all eat ate
alone and didn't really speak to each
other in ninth grade that's a tough
thing because you're not the loser in
the sense where you're not the biggest
loser where people come up and maybe
help you even because they feel bad for
you but yours you're enough of a loser
to where you are sitting at a table with
other people and you're not speaking you
do not have any social tenth-grade I got
a little better 11th grade I made a
group of friends and then 12th grade I
got nominated for homecoming king and I
was very popular and it was a journey
and there are rules and there are ways
to behave and we're gonna go through
this this is very important for people
out there that are listening people say
to me Oh things have changed now because
the social media yes and no yes and no
first rule if you are not popular it is
your fault 100 percent excusing the
people that I mentioned up top the
people getting fingered by grandpa let's
leave them out but if you are relatively
stable and you can handle what's going
on and you have regular teenage tanks or
whatever if you are not connecting with
people [ __ ] it's on you you are not
better and smarter than everybody else
maybe you are but if you're smarter than
everybody else you can figure out a way
to be their [ __ ] friend if you can
outsmart somebody you can outsmart your
way into their social [ __ ] circle
right manipulation manipulation currency
manipulation arbitrage [ __ ] stop
holding on to this this loserdom stop
holding on to this uh you think that
there's some value in being
misunderstood being some goth Daria type
[ __ ] whatever there is no value to that
there is no value to holding on to these
like you know these things that define
you as a
if they're driving everyone away right
okay
a lot of times that doesn't mean that to
be popular you have to be a perfect
person or you even have to be remarkably
talented a good-looking you don't you
just have to figure out what you're good
at and display it in an appropriate way
hmm
so few things off the top very general
rules know who the popular people are
and you do already but no the very
popular people are know who the A's and
then know who are the B's know who are
the safeties right know who's in the
scene but really shouldn't be know who's
self-conscious about not bringing a lot
to the table know the people that are
the third call to go to the party you're
gonna be their friend you're not going
to the top of the heap first you're
going to be friends with the person who
doesn't really belong in the popular
group who doesn't really get like the
fat vicious kid you're gonna befriend
net
you're gonna befriend the hanger-on yeah
the sporty Daiki chick who's good at
sports but is weird and somehow is out
all the parties she'll have some of them
at her house and everybody's like oh we
love you Jackie but no one loves Jackie
she looks like a horse but why is she
that there's always one girl in the
popular crowd that looks like a horse
she is a field hockey fire-breathing
Dyke and doesn't know it yet okay you
get on her radar or you get on the radar
of the kid who's rich but not cool rich
people by the way are never not cool
they just haven't grown into who they
are yet rich people will always be cool
they're cold and aloof because they're
different but around junior year senior
year they start driving their dads BMW
to school they start wearing nicer
clothes they grow into themselves they
grow into their wealth yeah they start
having parties at their house that house
is on the water it's got acreage people
are growing up and they're realizing
that there's more than just catching a
[ __ ] football this kid's got a dope
[ __ ] life be that guy's friend figure
way into his circle figure way into
horseface fire-breathing Dyke
Jackie Circle
your way into the circle of somebody who
doesn't belong in the group or somebody
who's marginal you need a marginal
figure in order to break in for the most
part right yeah that's really the way
you should be here's the other thing be
hungry and not desperate don't ever seem
desperate
always seem like you have plans but be
hungry to go do things with people be
hungry because you want to be there be
hungry because it's important that you
you go out and that you're seen
don't be desperate don't be clingy let
people call you let them text you don't
be the person who's constantly driving
it driving it you know it gets annoying
the people don't give people rides be
the first person with a car huge huge
huge be a person with a car be a person
with drugs be a person with a gun be a
person with bullets be a person be a
[ __ ] person be a person with a house
where you can have a party be a person
with a cool backyard take the initiative
what are people lacking what is a
popular group lack is it funny person
what is it be that try to be that if
you're good-looking so that if you're
funny sell that if you're completely
bland sell that people need bland right
okay they need somebody to really not
make any impressions and stand around
you want to be that guy be that [ __ ]
guy
okay here's the other thing this is the
thing people are gonna like I think
we've been pretty non-controversial so
far I'm on keto I'm a keto kid Brenda
job is supervising all of my meals I was
denied a smoothie but I was okayed my
egg breakfast which had Grove LA and
spinach don't [ __ ] with me folks your
loser friends gotta go they gotta go
Tommy who's been your friend forever who
shits himself he's got to go cuz he's
only your friend because you two also
suck you got to go you got to move the
[ __ ] on a little of it's over level the
[ __ ] up stop holding on to your old life
through old ideas your old friends they
suck they want you to suck and they want
you to die and there
be [ __ ] happy for you if you start to
do well the minute you go to a cool
party or somebody likes you they're
gonna [ __ ] change and then they're
gonna tell you that you've changed you
have changed okay but not in a
meaningful way you don't start treating
them like [ __ ] or anything but you're
just not gonna be relating to them as
much because they want to complain about
AB and everything and how much every
everyone sucks and then once people
don't suck a little bit it's rose the
dynamic laughs so they got a [ __ ] go
and it shouldn't be a long process they
got a [ __ ] go okay it'll be awkward
you know their parents it'll be awkward
it's fine they gotta go yeah okay yeah
Hollywood is is writes popular culture
popular culture is written by losers so
they fetish guys losers and make them
all into kings and queens and that they
all graduate and go on and write plays
and movies and sing songs and they all
become [ __ ] Fiona Apple no they don't
there's one Fiona Apple and the rest of
you were eating cat litter on your floor
you're eating your own vomit like a like
a cat okay you're not feeling an apple
you don't have you stop cut it out
you're not that person okay so let's
stop pretending but Hollywood will make
you think you can be and they'll make
you think that all those popular people
they all they all you know they hit a
ceiling and they don't do it know that
they're fine they're fine law of
averages let's go by the numbers they're
fine they become people like logan paul
george w bush cardi B Donald Trump and
myself icons the thing here folks is
I've always considered myself a business
strategist in addition to being a
comedian being a comedian just something
I do but my heart my passion has always
been in business you know I've always
been you know CEO it's the way I feel
just see y'all have that mentality of
the winner's mentality and if you don't
I pity you I wish you were dead but
you're not you're here on earth and I
have to look at you and it disgusts me
because I've always been a CEO now you
say to me Tim
everything you've done in the business
world has been a tremendous failure you
foreclosed on houses you worked for
companies that went out of business hey
shut the [ __ ] up okay cuz that's facts
that's reality and if you live in that
world
you're a [ __ ] I'm a business man I
create my own reality I manifest my
reality every day I get up and I say
here's how it's gonna be not how it is
not how it was here's how it's gonna be
I have tools I have a toolbox and I take
the tools out of the toolbox and I make
[ __ ] okay
I build businesses you even know what
that is
I build businesses right now I am
working on a multi-platform
multi-dimensional business that will
exist in several dimensions while you
[ __ ] are still on earth in our
dimension like [ __ ] losers trying to
play catch-up okay I'm working I'm
thinking about space tourism the [ __ ]
are you doing I'm trying to build a
business okay what are my tools I'll
tell you a great tool great tools Wix
Wix is a place where you can start a
website you might not have a lot of
money so you can go to Wix and you could
choose from one of 500 templates for
your website or you could you know you
could create your own or you could have
Wix ad I do it automated ad I artificial
design intelligence you answer a few
simple questions about your business
what is your business space tourism
what's the business gonna be a hotel
where is it gonna be located on the
[ __ ] moon [ __ ] and then whoops we'll
design a website that lets everybody
know oh these guys are opening a [ __ ]
hotel on the moon I don't give a [ __ ]
government permits I'll bribe those
[ __ ] I know how that works okay
you blackmailed you bribe you coerce you
intimidate you manipulate okay but you
gotta let people know what you're doing
you gotta let people know you're gonna
open the dopest hotel on the moon I'm
talking and it's not gonna be hacky like
a lot of these moon hotels I'm gonna be
hacky they'll have moon pies it'll be a
space theme my hotel is not gonna be a
space theme okay it's not gonna be a
space it's gonna be a tropical theme
which is gonna throw people because
they're on the [ __ ] moon and zero
gravity and it's gonna be that moon
crater wasteland and then I'm gonna have
a tropical theme a lot of people are
gonna do Space Age I'm gonna do tropical
it's gonna throw everybody you're gonna
be you're gonna be in a Cabana so we're
gonna create a beach we could have our
own wave pool I'm giving it away for
free because I'm so confident none of
you [ __ ] are able to touch me
you're not able to you can't execute the
way I can execute because it's not just
about having an idea it's about
execution and the first step is having a
website that allows people in you're
gonna let them in and you gotta let them
in and go hey [ __ ] here's here's the
here's your new moon hotel Wix is cheap
okay I'm not trying to spend a lot of
money up front on the website because
this is gonna sell itself the concept is
gonna sell itself okay it's gonna sell
itself because people gonna want to go
to the moon and they're not gonna go to
wanted some dumb moon hotel they want to
go to a tropical resort on the [ __ ]
moon
okay picture it you walk into the lobby
and it's got big tropical trees some
parrots in the [ __ ] Lobby and I don't
give a [ __ ] about the Animal Control
people tell me I'm abusing animals
they're lucky to work those animals are
lucky to work so I'm gonna get a bunch
of parrots and a lizard or two and it's
gonna be fun the kids are gonna love it
you're gonna love it you're gonna walk
in you're gonna feel like you're in a
tropical rainforest but you're not
you're on the [ __ ] moon you're on
another planet you dumb [ __ ] and you're
gonna love it we're gonna have room
service we're gonna have like if you go
to the hotel and you wake up in the
middle of the night and you're hungry
we're gonna have like
we're gonna have chicken fingers but
like with the Jamaican Jerk spice
seasoning it's gonna be real hot because
you're gonna be on the moon and the moon
is is I think it's cold so what you're
gonna have is you're gonna have like
spicy spicy like hot tropical food we're
like Amalek shrimp skewers with like a
mango salsa and it's gonna be all
[ __ ] rainforest theme you know like
the rainforest cafe but high-end you
know it's gonna cost a lot of money to
go to this resort you'd have to spend
about a million at night it's not gonna
be for people that aren't rich it's
gonna be for rich people that want to
spend that money okay we're gonna have a
pool is gonna be a wave pool gonna have
lifeguards they're all gonna be trained
so if you want to take your family to
the moon and spend 4 or 5 mil to have a
tropical experience on the moon you
could go to my website if you want to go
to Wix and build your own website don't
take my idea I don't give a [ __ ] you can
build a hotel on the moon don't pull the
tropical hotel
I'll [ __ ] come for you you built you
choose another [ __ ] theme you do what
all these dumb [ __ ] are gonna do some
dumb moon theme it's not gonna be like
that with mine I don't give a [ __ ] about
space other than that's this is in space
okay there's not gonna be like facts
about the moon and [ __ ] you know these
dumb companies gonna put like some dumb
moon hotel it's gonna be little Space
Age and cold it's gonna feel cold it's
gonna be like everything's gonna be
white and cold and it's gonna be sterile
it's not that's not what I'm about I'm
about like bug nets over the beds even
though there's not gonna be any bugs
it's just nice because you're gonna be
transported back to earth and feel like
you're on earth and we're gonna have
like fake sunsets in the dining room
we're gonna have a restaurant and it's
gonna be awesome man that's it's gonna
be [ __ ] awesome because the
rainforest is burning right now so
you're not gonna have that no longer if
you want real nature you're gonna have
to go to the moon to my resort
because most of the rainforest is being
burnt to the ground by I don't know
people in Brazil for whatever reason but
I respect them I respect their business
I don't question it they need to do what
they got to do it's not my problem you
know what I mean so the reality is if
you want that rainforest feeling pretty
soon you're gonna have to take a
spaceship to the moon we're gonna have
it's gonna be great hotel we're not
going to have the maids bothering you at
like 7:00 a.m. trying to get in your
[ __ ] room like sometimes you go to a
hotel like you go to Mary a courtyard
and they knock on the door like nine
o'clock and you scream at them but they
don't understand English so you gotta
you got they open the door anyway and
you're just [ __ ] laying there and
you're naked you're on the floor you
couldn't even get to the bed last night
and and they start screaming when they
see you because you still have chocolate
on your face from that [ __ ] lava cake
you ate and you start screaming back at
them yeah and then you shut the door and
feared that's not what we're doing we're
gonna have a high-tech system where if
you want your room clean you're gonna
type it in and then somebody's gonna
know and they're gonna show up and
they're gonna clean your room when you
want it clean they're not gonna show up
okay early in the [ __ ] morning that's
not the way it's gonna work
we have 24 hour day room service
tropical-themed will have volleyball you
know but it's not gonna be hyper
competitive where everybody's losing
their minds it's gonna be very
supportive volleyball you know where the
nets are gonna be like lower and because
of the gravity it's gonna be fun because
the balls will go everywhere okay I'm
telling you it's [ __ ] gonna be dope
I'm very excited about it and Wix is an
asset so if you go to Tim Dylan's going
to he'll calm T I am Dylan D il L ons
going to hell calm you can then find you
go to the bottom of the site you'll find
a link and the link is going to take you
to Wix you'll get 10% off any of their
premium plans if you want to open a
hotel a resort you want to do it on
earth like a [ __ ] like you're living
in 1996 good for you I have no interest
in that we're breaking ground next month
on my moon resort but we're gonna call
it we're gonna call paradise on the moon
and it's very this is why I'm successful
because I have vision many of you do not
have vision
and it's disgusting but whatever man try
out your shitty business maybe it'll
work which is a great place you know now
and I don't smoke and this podcast gives
people the idea that smoke cuz they
smoke during the podcast to give me
energy to tell the truth right yeah
Marlboro Lights they're not just for
Asians but Asians love them
Asians love a light cigarette because
they're responsible now know where you
can get [ __ ] up and act like a pig and
know where you have to be a person my
one of my best friends was named Jill
monster Jill monster had the funnest
house and his parents are my good
friends I I when I graduated school I
bought a house it was rapidly foreclosed
on and I became a regular at several
local gin mills in my town and began to
the process of throwing my life away by
becoming a degenerate alcoholic a thief
a liar and and in his parents were two
of my best friends I love them so much
they're amazing [ __ ] people his house
was a house we could kind of let it all
out be wild be crazy but if you went to
my friend Maeve's house her parents were
rich so you have to you have to behave
don't vomit all over the house with the
nice carpet do you know what I mean yeah
there are houses where you can let it
all hang out and then there are houses
and people where you have to be a little
more guarded don't always be a hundred
percent of yourself no one wants that no
one needs that no who wants what when I
could go to my friend Joe's house at
3:00 in the morning drunk having just
hit a car asking to be hid from the
police and his parents were not only
happy to see me they would provide me a
meal not everyone's like that not
everyone's like that when you're hiding
in the Attic because you just hit and
ran someone not everyone's gonna come
out with a ball of seafood gumbo many
people are gonna tell you to leave so
you got to know where should I go you
got to figure that out you know
you have a friend or like a house where
you could hang out and have fun and just
go crazy and nobody would worry yeah
yeah there was where we watch porn and
you know yeah baby we knew we had a room
that they never checked on us the
parents and you could just wake up in
the middle of the night and go make food
in the kitchen be loud yes and they
could do whatever you want and no one
would care and you would you could just
you abuse people and they would abuse
you and that's a beautiful [ __ ] thing
yeah really it's an it's a beautiful
thing and it needs to happen you need to
have those situations where you exchange
abuse and then there are places where
you have to look a little nicer put it
together don't look like a slob you
gotta be able to kind of judge where
you're at you gotta pick your spots you
gotta pick your samanta Lee put on a
suit and tie
absolutely great way to say it let's
talk about some potential personalities
for the kids personality number one you
can choose barstool sports which means
that you're just a bro yeah
you're kind of racist but not really
you're just a bro
you just want to watch sports talk about
sports maybe get your dick sock you
don't really offer anything yeah but
every now and then you have tender
moments and you'll let your straight
friend see your penises or you let your
gay friend who doesn't know he's gay yet
see your day okay that's important for
whoever that kid is yeah you can have
tender moments but you're you're a bro
but you have a big heart you like family
you want people coming over to your
house you want to go to their houses you
like surrogate families barstool sports
great personality boat shoes salmon
shirt no shoes salmon shorts the world
thinks for a rapist but you're not you
can barely pull your little wink out in
front of a girl the world thinks you're
running everything but you're really not
you're more scared than anybody else is
out there yeah but you cover it up with
bravado and whatever it's barstool
sports and that personality in your 30s
is horrendous and many people still have
it Saturday's are for the boys no
they're not for the boys they're for job
interviews clean your life up shave your
life
okay nothing's for the boys you're
uploading this from your [ __ ]
mother's the house barstool sports weed
next personality weed you love weed you
love skating you love snowboarding
you're a weed person that's what you do
maybe a sell weed maybe you know how to
get the best weed that's what gets you
and all the things because you just you
look weed now you talk about that you're
gonna start your own weed started in
weed company and you love weed and
that's all you talk about and you just
smoke weed and it is what it is and
you're a skinny kid you have a big dick
and you love fettuccine alfredo when you
love weed that's it just weed on you
we'll get you in so many circles you
need to have weed on you all the time if
weed is gonna be your personality your
car always smells like weed you bake
every single morning people bake with
you they think it's funny they think
you're a disaster but they don't really
tell you to your face they're scared for
what's gonna happen to you and you will
destroy your life two years out of high
school
that being said who gives a [ __ ] we're
only talking about those four golden
years it'll get you into the good
parties it'll be fun you're a bacon egg
and cheese guy you like getting high
it's 2:00 a.m. and talk about your a lot
of [ __ ] fun maybe you're a gamer and
yeah everyone smokes weed you're on
Twitch and whatever four people are
giving you $3 and whatever it's fun it
is what it is okay Nazi gamer is the
next personality you're not seeing a
gamer you're a race realist you believe
in the JQ you are hardcore red pills and
I mean you throw back the pills with
abandon you're in the fitness because
you're ready to fight a race war your
name online is like Nordic warrior 1488
or something like that you know what I
mean you're hardcore into it you know
all of this is because some chick
wouldn't [ __ ] you you decided to read 15
books about the shape of skulls because
you couldn't get laid but that's a
personality and stick to it
here's another personality guy who talks
about war crimes at a party that's the
other side black bloc you want to be an
anther foe but you don't know where they
meet up you wear black all the time you
want to just throw a rock at a proud boy
but you can't find one cuz you live in a
[ __ ] New England town and everybody
kind of agrees with you
in fact you hate neo liberals more than
anything you rail against centrist and
boomers and everybody that [ __ ] the
whole world up even though you'd [ __ ] it
up too if you had any [ __ ] goddamn
chance at it which you probably won't
because thankfully climate change will
ravage the earth before you get a chance
to show what a [ __ ] incompetent [ __ ]
you really are it's the other side of
nazi gamer you're actually friends with
a nazi gamer even though you don't
really like each other you think you're
the other ones abhorrent but you would
probably like to [ __ ] hardcore one day
and it might happen who knows right but
you're both are not too good with women
you're just the other side of it you
bury yourself in books or whatever some
people are impressed by your knowledge
and the fact that you use big words but
it's all concealing that you have
roiling rage and inner turmoil inside
because your mother's never looked at
you the way she's looked at wine another
personality missing person missing
person is the type of personality you
cannot go to school a lot when you go to
school you have to sit absolutely
slightly in the back of the room and in
the middle of a class you just start
screaming then you run out and you
disappear for two weeks then you're back
then you're gone then you're back then
you're gone
nobody knows where you are is the state
taking control of you nobody knows but
you're all over the place and you're
nowhere are you a runaway did you escape
from a pedophile call to you trying to
get into a pedophile call you're a
missing person nobody knows your deal
and you can't let them because you're
bland and nobody gives a [ __ ]
but you disguise it by being this kind
of chaotic ball of crazy missing-person
fat girl with a clean car we've gone
through this you're fat but you have a
tight ponytail you have an immaculate
car you drive everyone to every party
you say very little you love smoking a
lot of weed and you never eat in front
of people but at the end of the night
you go park your car and you deep throat
an entire [ __ ] pizza you are the fat
girl with the clean car you are a
[ __ ] American legend okay you do not
say much you do not talk you were there
to be or you're a bus driver essentially
you have a car it's usually a midsize
SUV little truck things like that could
be a little coupe or whatever you'll
pack four or five thin people in two it
doesn't matter you
we stay sober enough to drive that's how
you bring to the table don't start
getting [ __ ] up now and if you get too
[ __ ] up to drive you have to let
somebody else drive your car and it
doesn't matter whether they have a
license or not you are the fat girl with
the clean car you're here to save the
[ __ ] day okay but don't ever have an
opinion or say anything
it'll be greeted with weirdness you
speak in 3 to 4 word things usually
about traffic oh there's a [ __ ]
accident here then you're done for the
night
then you're done for the night yeah hey
yeah don't provide too much fat girl
with the clean car insanely gay person
you are insanely gay you are the gayest
person ever you are made of literal calm
you were gay and you want everyone to
know you're gay and you'll suck them off
you're gonna [ __ ] a lot of hot straight
guys doing this ok you're a lot
better-looking to me of a six-pack you
were a dancer and you can [ __ ] a lot of
straight guys in the bathroom when
they're not looking you're you're part
of the theater crew but not really
because you really want to suck off a
football player because who wants to
[ __ ] another [ __ ] a guy that you've
been dancing around with all day so
you're the insanely gay person you put
it out there and the football guys to
kind of discuss it by you but some of
them you know if the girlfriend wasn't
around and if it was late enough at
night would probably let you swallow
their hog you know and it's very
important that you be you're an insanely
gay person obnoxiously gay over-the-top
you've got 15 pride flags on you at all
times you're throwing them at people
you're the insanely gay person white guy
who wants to be black or who thinks he
is black
if you come from the Northeast these are
Jews who think they're Italian who want
to be black you say things like young
man and son and somehow you get away
with it you hang out with the black kids
but then you also hang with the white
kids every now and then you've been
accepted
you're usually rich hmm you love black
culture you love rap music you love
everything black you look at your own
skin and you wish you could [ __ ] take
a [ __ ] a potato peeler and just skin
yourself every night and wake up and be
a glorious nubian God but you can't it's
not what it is you don't have that big
black dick you've got a you know
respectable Jewish pecker
but you love black people that's the way
it is it is nothing wrong with that
that's that
I mean should you be more comfortable in
your own skin perhaps I'm not here to
judge that's your personality stick to
it okay
that's who you're gonna be yeah that's a
common one that's a common one and it
does very well hmm you know uh it does
very well um [ __ ] who fights you're a
[ __ ] and you're always fighting you
have two best friends and you fight them
every day physically over the phone
you're just fighting or [ __ ] you
exist in one of two states fighting or
[ __ ] you're either [ __ ] three guys
at a party or you're fighting six girls
in a park either way that's who you are
you're drama you bring it to the table
you wish you were Puerto Rican but
you're just Italian you know if you want
to be one of those city tough girls but
you're not okay you had some weird [ __ ]
with your uncle early on you didn't
process that so you just want to fight
everybody you see you've punched your
boyfriend in the face and then had the
best sex afterwards when you choked the
[ __ ] out of each other
you probably [ __ ] a teacher and if not
you should you've posted an ad on
Backpage here there yeah you you're 17
but you aren't seeking arrangements and
if a few businessmen want to buy you
some dinner and throw you some money for
shoes who the [ __ ] are you to judge it
doesn't matter you're a fighter and
you're a [ __ ] that's what you are
maybe your name's like Angela or
something you like to throw the [ __ ]
down what did you say to me you're
always ready to fight anything so people
don't get inside of you and see who you
really are
which is a scared little girl a scared
and traumatized little girl but you're
not gonna be Billy Eilish and have a
bunch of candles lit and go and make
millions of dollars you're gonna fight
or you're gonna [ __ ] that's who you are
yeah fat girl who doesn't know she's fat
this is big
you have no idea you're fat you hang out
with all the popular girls
you wonder why their boyfriends aren't
[ __ ] you you're genuinely stunt your
perplex that you are not getting more
play you have no idea why this is
happening
you're fun you kid around with everybody
everybody loves you you like them you're
everybody's little sister
somebody [ __ ] you wants when they're
really loaded and you make it out to be
more than it really is you don't know
that you're a chub-o but you kind of own
it and then you also kind of don't own
it and then when it comes to prom you
really try to doll it up those girls
really go crazy at prom because they
think one dress is gonna cover up what
they've been doing for the last [ __ ]
four years you know yeah the fat girl
has no idea she's fat the fat guy who
talks about [ __ ] all the time but never
gets it and wouldn't know what to do if
he did get it you're a fat guy and you
just want to [ __ ] checks your best
friends are hot guys it [ __ ] girls all
the time you're on the football team
you're decent at it but nobody wants to
touch you you're very angry you drink
all the time
you love fighting because it's a way
that you can show that you have some
value on this [ __ ] planet nobody
really calls you to hang out but they
like having you around when it's a big
party because you're just a big lug
you're hammered and all you care about
is push you really get any [ __ ] puss
here you'll pretend and not want to go
someplace if somebody calls you a girly
girls there but you don't give a [ __ ]
you know if there were girls here
they're not [ __ ] taking your dick out
of your [ __ ] dough body pants yeah
it's not gonna happen
but you tell everybody hey I just want
to make sure there's enough [ __ ]
there before I show up [ __ ] you but
that's that's an important archetype of
person kid whose mother's a teacher
who's kind of a goody two-shoes but lets
it all out with one party or two parties
and he vomits the whole time because
this is the first time it's usually
senior year he's letting himself loose
and he's got a girlfriend he'll keep her
for four years he kind of goes to the
popular parties for 15 minutes nobody
remembers him maybe his class president
maybe he's in the student government
maybe he's somebody like that whatever
and every now and then he'll get really
really hammered and vomit all over the
place but he knows he's an establishment
guy he's a foul
he's or whatever he's got the right
opinions in the right package you know
yeah yeah yeah you know talks to the
teacher after class a lot yes yeah
lesbian who works a lot of jobs and lets
everyone know how hard she works could
be a catering hall could be a restaurant
but she's always working and she's
always working and she wants everyone to
know how hard she works and how much
responsibility her job gives her it's a
great way to not take stock of where she
is in the whole social fabric of
everything usually it's a lesbian and
she's working she's been working since
she's four years old it's a claim that
she's managing some some thing or
whatever this is these are the
personalities some of the personalities
there's an innumerable amount of
personalities there's not an innumerable
amount of genders although that's not a
bad idea if you're a bland white check
you can just dye your hair green you say
I'm they/them my new name is uh you know
Astrid or whatever you know you look up
some constellation name yourself after
that you're now a new person and you
know I talked about a new business idea
that I had earlier where I was gonna
open a tropical resort on the moon and
it's gonna be like a resort like a hotel
like a high-end tropical hotel it's
gonna be on the moon but it will not
have a moon or a space theme it will
have a tropical theme and because the
rainforest is being burned on Earth the
only real rainforest you're gonna get is
at my resort on the moon and I'm gonna
have a big Resort and a big Resort is
very complex to run you got to run it
okay that's why I'm gonna use Monday
comm because Monday comm keeps everybody
in line okay there's nothing worse than
looking for emails and yelling at people
blaming people screaming that's not the
way it's gonna be
Monday comm a software that enhances the
effectiveness of your business plan it
allows you to coordinate and collaborate
with people it is a [ __ ] very
easy-to-use tool that keeps everybody
accountable people people I will fire
people at my tropical moon resort if
they [ __ ] up I don't care I don't care
I'm not trying to hear your mouth it
doesn't matter to me
to understand me I will straight up lose
my mind
and start Sookie and I don't want to do
that I don't want to scream in Allah
because the whole thing is tropical
relaxation make it people feel good I
don't want to have to go up to the front
desk and start banging people's heads
around literally but I will if they if
they don't do what I want them to do
which is so important to have a thing
like Monday calm many of you have
business it's perfect Monday calm if
you're two people collaborating or
there's thousands of people around the
globe or in space like I'm gonna have
it's a perfect tool to make sure that
everybody is on the same page
everybody's United everybody's connected
it's very important to me to have an
efficient Resort on the moon with a
tropical theme okay we're gonna have
like maybe like 800 guest rooms and 200
of them are gonna be suites the guest
room is gonna cost a million tonight the
Suites gonna make 5 million a night and
the Suites are gonna have like a
separate room for you to kind of relax
and sit it'll have a separate sitting
room and it'll probably have like a
balcony or a terrace but the guest rooms
will not have that the Suites will and
then then there will be villas the
villas like above Suites and then the
villas in order because this is very
complex in order to keep this all going
you need Monday dot-com okay if you have
a business out there and you're
disorganized Monday calm is essential
we're starting to use it here we're
building a little tiny business right
now with the podcast just trying to
entertain people getting people out to
live shows but that's not my main goal
my main goal is to open a tropical
resort on the moon within five years and
it will happen but it's only gonna
happen if I stay organized and efficient
a lot of people out there are not
organized I used to work in a mortgage
company and a lot of people you know
you'd always be like Doreen where's that
email in Doreen would know because she's
stupid right she'd be like I don't know
where it is I just saw it and then
you're like oh [ __ ] my life is over
because I can't get to what I need to
get to that's not good I don't have time
for that when I'm running a thousand
room Resort on the moon I'm not gonna
have time for that I'm gonna need people
to be efficient you understand what I
mean another thing I'm gonna have so I'm
gonna have big fish tanks you know
because he's not fish in outer space but
people are gonna want to feel
comfortable because when people go to
the moon they're gonna be like I feel
like I'm not on earth
which is good because that's why they're
traveling but they're gonna want some
comforts creature comforts things that
remind them of home fish tanks
okay so I'll have fish tanks and I might
have like dogs and cats to make people
feel like they're at home and we might
do the thing we're like if you want a
dog or a cat sent to your room for an
hour to pet we're gonna be able to do
that and we're gonna have an email
system and we're gonna be able to we're
gonna be able to make sure that all of
the scheduling is efficient and so that
if you request a dog you're like hey
send the lab up to room 1512 and I send
one up and you're like oh man I feel
like I'm at home like I was weirded out
when I first got here because I was on
the moon but now I'm not weirded out I'm
really enjoying this because you sent up
a lab you know maybe a chocolate lab or
a golden lab and there's a you know
beautiful dog or a cat you know you send
up a cat and cats are kind of vicious
and cold but still there's something
about them that makes you feel at home
and that's important that's what the
whole resorts about it's like you're far
away from home but how are you that's
the whole thing but are you that's
really what I want you to feel like you
don't really know like you do like oh
[ __ ] I feel like I'm on a tropical
resort a two-hour plane ride from my
house but not you're in the middle of
space you're in outer space at my
tropical moon resort and it's gonna be
called paradise on the moon and I mean a
lot of people doubt me and they don't a
lot of people don't take me seriously
when I tell them this specifically uber
drivers but that's okay because that's
what your rating is based on not your
driving it's do you get lend credibility
to my dreams or not and if you kind of
laugh at me when I say this not only
will I rate you low but I'll try to I'll
try to make you get in an accident in a
way that will only hurt you and not me
so Monday calm what's the promo code
here Monday calm slash Tim monday calm
slash Tim if you have a business and you
want to be effective you want to be
efficient you want to keep track of
where all these emails are going where
all these appointments are going if
you're in sales marketing anything
you're doing if you're running a resort
on the moon whatever it happens to be
you're gonna need a business plan Monday
comm is a software that allows you to
streamline everything you're doing it's
so much easier makes it very simple so
that's
really what we're trying to do so if
you're into that if you're trying to be
somebody you know I think Monday comm /
Tim is the way to do it go there and
start thinking about squeezing more
money out of your business holding
people accountable because I can tell
already like my first speech I'm gonna
give to my staff I'm gonna walk into the
hotel I'm gonna say this is my dream and
they're all gonna look at me and they're
gonna be they're gonna be amazed and I'm
gonna say this is my dream I'm gonna say
because we have money calm we're gonna
hold you accountable you're not gonna
get away with nothing here you're not
getting away with it don't tell me you
didn't get a message or that you lost an
email we didn't know when a meeting was
gonna be because we'll throw you right
in a black hole we'll throw you in outer
space cuz I'm gonna have the staff sign
waivers that that they're that they
understand that we can we can remove
them from the resort and once you're out
of the resort you can't on your own in
space and a lot of people aren't going
to be able to do so that it is real like
the threat of doing bad is real it's not
fake it's not like one of those things
we just quit whatever is where you gonna
go
you know Jupiter's not hospitable to
life so Monday that kind of should be no
excuses understand me so Monday dot-com
/ Tim and if you're interested in my
paradise on the moon Resort will be
making a formal announcement pretty soon
and a lot of people trying to do this
Richard Richard Branson and lick Bezos
from all those guys but I'm not afraid
of them because none of them understand
how to make people feel at home on
another planet and I do I get it you
know because we're gonna have like the
best thing I think sometimes about a
hotel is you have a breakfast buffet now
we're gonna have like a breakfast buffet
and it's gonna be awesome and one of the
things that's gonna make it different
from other breakfast buffets is that
it's gonna be on the moon
and you're gonna have big windows as you
eat breakfast that look out into space
and that's gonna be [ __ ] nice like a
lot of people don't do that like the
buffet room is like a dump it'll almost
look like a conference room but ours is
gonna be very nice with huge windows
that look out onto a space station so
that when you're eating a waffle with
your family you're like what should we
do today you know you know there's gonna
be activities but I don't want to go
into all the acts I don't want people
copying my [ __ ] you're gonna get a free
14-day trial if you go to Monday comm
slash Jim thank you
here's the other thing so now let's go
back to some actual specifics don't
trust there's a few people you should
never trust never trust the popular girl
who's in theater this girl has divided
loyalties she really wants to be popular
but she thinks she's an actress what she
really is is mentally ill people like
that will pretend to be your friend
because they fancy themselves to be
humanitarians and they like to befriend
losers and put them in their pocket but
when it matters they'll never have your
back and they don't really like you
they're always gonna choose the popular
people because they're not [ __ ]
stupid so any popular - if you're a
popular chick you should be a [ __ ] and
you should walk around like a [ __ ] own
it like if you're a rich person be rich
don't go to open mics don't be you know
do be what you are so don't trust that
person that's a person you have to watch
out for the person with divided
loyalties and a lot of times it's the
girl who's popular but like oh don't
make fun of this kid yeah and then
she'll befriend you a little too nice to
the disenfranchised a little too nice to
the disenfranchised she thinks that you
know you you you are in love with her
probably or you like God that she's
gonna you know one day she's gonna bring
you to all the cool places it whatever
none of that's ever gonna [ __ ] happen
okay so don't trust her she has divided
loyalty she's she it's duality she split
herself into two people okay the popular
girl and then the girl that feels
secretly a little insecure around macro
and she wants to be better than them and
she thinks she can do it by being a
third-rate member of the theater group
okay yeah so this is these are people to
watch out for kids I hope this is
helpful to many of you out there I mean
many of you are irredeemable losers and
can't be helped but I'm trying to help
him do my best to help you you know what
else cuz there are some there are there
some other important things spend your
summers getting ready to be the person
you want to be when you get back into
school get in shape be the fat kid who
comes back hot be the goody two-shoes
who come
back a drug-dealer be the kid that
wasn't serious about school who comes
back getting all A's change
people love a drastic change they love a
drastic change that was me I changed you
know people love change I became
outgoing and funny and I lost weight I
looked better and all of that [ __ ]
matters they love a drastic change allow
the summer to be the place that you
change and you become something else if
your parents were rich use that money if
your parents are animals use that allow
people to come and have parties at your
house and absolutely destroy it light it
on fire it doesn't matter
hey you don't like these jokes here's
what you can do if you don't like these
[ __ ] jokes you can take them and
shove it up your ass but you [ __ ]
degenerates would love that don't ya
you would love a [ __ ] couple of
things up your ass you free love freaks
sex don't get too into it unless you
really know what you're doing don't be
super weird about it you don't need to
be [ __ ] all the time
mmm it's more about friendship than not
if you have a girlfriend that's fine you
should be hooking up with people
whatever but don't force that aspect
don't become obsessed with it don't
become crazy you know don't become the
guy that's obsessed with getting laid
then you never do you know yeah don't
become the girl that uses sex as a
weapon unless you know what you're
[ __ ] doing and you can really use it
as a weapon you start blackmailing
people you know yeah have a healthy
relationship with your family but don't
be too like get other families get
surrogate families go on vacations with
people be independent start this young
right go on summer vacation if families
are taking on vacations it means you
really like you and love you that's very
important if you like a young socialite
yes be a young socialite get out of your
comfort zone do [ __ ] you wouldn't
necessarily think of yourself doing
challenge yourself that movie eighth
grade with Bo Burnham is a decent movie
it's not a bad movie Bo Burnham is a
genius I don't know him but he
genius I don't love some of like he does
this one thing where he's like I'm an
artist and he's singing this thing is
like I'm an artist we shouldn't be here
we should be feeding families it's like
that's not how it works no one made the
decision to not feed a family to come
see this comedy show right that's not
the way the economy works
it has structural problems that's not it
just go be a cheat Shia LaBeouf just go
be a genius I don't want to hear from
you I don't want to hear a podcast just
make a brilliant thing and I'm all on
board for it we're all gonna go and
great okay and that movie eighth grades
good because it's a girl that feels that
she's not in and then she goes to this
party that you got invited to that she
feels weird about be that person and
then she wants to be with the kid that's
good-looking but she ends up being with
the goofball kid you know because the
kid is good-looking kind of a deck and
asks her to bomb yeah I don't don't
bully people don't [ __ ] on people if
you're gonna be funny never build your
act around another kid they could
transfer they could kill themselves and
you got to build from zero don't be
cruel you should never be cruel in my
yearbook which I should have gotten out
and read the things people wrote about
me like you never made fun of anybody
but you're [ __ ] hilarious
punch-up not in my world comedy I should
be able to punch wherever but in high
school punch up make fun of teachers you
know impersonate teachers yeah get good
impressions make fun of the proposal
VIII friends with teachers be cool be
able to be late know how to do it know
when you can joke around and when you
can that's the other thing a lot of
people in that quote-unquote popular
group are very insecure and threatened
so no one you can [ __ ] on them and no
one you could joke around with them and
know when you can know what you can say
when you can say it read them look at
people and read them what do you want
from them and what do they want from you
there's nothing wrong with analyzing
that dynamic relationships it doesn't
make you a sociopath it makes you aware
know what things to bring up to the
teacher that you know the teacher will
then talk about forever and that's you
don't do any work and then all like you
cuz you keep bringing up something in
distract a hundred percent know what you
can do in a class to get some attention
there was a moment in Spanish class
where I never knew what the word meant
I didn't care but we're in America speak
English but we would go and she goes
what is helada and a lot Oh ironically
means ice cream and I should have known
that but I didn't know that it meant ice
cream so I just said a little pudding
and it was very funny I said a little
pudding and it killed and she went no
and she laughed out
she laughed it was okay if you're funny
it'll all be okay not at my age not a 34
it's gonna be hell it's gonna end so bad
I can't even describe to you the end
it'll be so bad my landlord just texted
me if the bugs in my room have been
fixed if the to stay somewhere because
the bugs are apparently they've won
insane Giuliani and Trump jr. we're at
the stand tonight oh wow
I shouldn't went you know what folks I'm
where I need to be a [ __ ] Holly [ __ ]
I'm in Hollywood people tell me oh you
missed out oh did I I'm in Hollywood
have you heard of it
I've been meeting them all in the pain
how do you pronounce groped idiot yes
yes I do with the guy who did American
vandal we're gonna sit there and stare
at each other and eat you know fast food
smoked salmon or whatever the place that
place shoves out it's important it's
important to be popular ma'am it's
important to be cool it's important to
have people like you be fun be cool you
know drink or smoke or don't or be
whatever but just be the person that
people want to be around just fill in
the blanks fill in the blanks is a great
way to say it Devin it's a great [ __ ]
way to say fill in the blanks don't hold
on to the old conception of who you are
being a loser doesn't make you special
or interesting everybody's a loser trust
me I know I'm surrounded by lots of that
many of them have millions and millions
of dollars
okay money in real estate don't fix the
fact that you suck Oscars and Emmys
won't fix the fact that you suck
sometimes you just [ __ ] suck and the
people that suck always know they
[ __ ] suck doesn't matter how much
money they have that's why they're
always killing themselves
how long have you done been 45 we're
gonna wrap this up pretty soon because
we got to do
and this was a pretty intense episode
and I think a lot of people have learned
a lot and maybe there are people that
are confused and maybe the message
wasn't for you pretty good I think it
was a great list I think there are some
great strategies this is how to do it
this is how to make it happen go in
there with a goal big I don't want to be
a loser I want to be cool what's an
attainable friend how do I step on his
head to get to that person who's whose
shoulders can I stand on to get to where
I need to go there's nothing wrong with
that okay
did you lose your friends it's over it
doesn't matter
but I've been friends with Billis and
shut up bring them with you and if you
can't you can and by the way go places
alone go to parties alone hang out
places alone it'll endear you to people
people will be forced you'll be forced
to go and talk to people be alone be
confident maybe go with one other person
you know he's a great person go with the
fat girl with the clean car because
she'll never outshine you yeah okay you
might not even come into the party
she'll come in variety she'll stand in
the backyard and smoke cigarettes and
then wait and you'll get in that
beautiful car and the Loess smell so
nice like a cherry air freshener or
something the ocean breeze or something
don't go and hang out don't don't bring
a crew you can't elevate a crew you can
elevate yourself you cannot elevate a
crew elevate yourself and then bring the
crew with you it's the way it is it's
the wave [ __ ] it is man and that's it I
mean there's not too much house I mean
the reality of the situation is this
most of you will fail I'm like talking
to the troops of d-day now most of you
going to the beach some of you are gonna
get shot in the head while you still on
the boat remember that scene Saving
Private Ryan you're shot in the head
before you're out of the boat you don't
even touch the beach you don't even feel
the glory of war you just dead you're a
flag on someone's [ __ ] mantle you're
a picture in a picture frame in a house
that nobody even goes in some old ladies
scares you and goes
Jimmy no one cares your ghost
most of you will be ghosts and most of
you you know at that point what else do
you really have there's nothing wrong
with that I know so many people that
should have been killed in Iraq they
never were in the military but I look at
them and I say you should have died for
the country you should have died a hero
you should have died a hero but for some
of you for small percentage of you for
the ones that are in the game for those
that have a chance for the fighters the
people that can make it join the team I
joined swim team it was hilarious I was
a good swimmer yeah one of my friends
said to me once because you smoke three
cigarettes on the way to this practice I
said yeah you guys I read you like a
book it was a funny moment we no longer
speak the point is this immediately
after you leave high school none of
these people will matter and you'll
never see them again don't try to hold
on to friendships with them it's
embarrassing there are people to
practice on you practice figuring [ __ ]
out on these people that are temporary
in your life you've had some brilliant
insights here you really have you've
done I'm telling you and very well here
they are people to practice on have you
ever tried to trim your ball hair with a
steak knife or a pair of scissors or a
flame an open flame it's an absolute
nightmare it's not good not good
especially if you're gonna go out on a
date and you might need to be ready
taking an old pair of rusty scissors
from a draw that you have an open since
you were a little kid you got
construction paper in there and glue
take it out that old pair of rusty
scissors from the early Clinton
administration and putting it near your
balls where your future bankrupt
children live is a bad move it's not
good
think about grazing
your sack with something sharp stop
thinking about it if that excites you
it's not good you don't want that nobody
wants a bloody penis that is such a rule
people do not want a bloody dick
they just don't it's important to
manscape with the right tools not rusty
scissors not a butter knife not
gardening utensils you found you gotta
do something better treat yourself and
treat whoever's going down and exploring
that area face to face up close and
personal that's the way it is there are
not that many products on the market for
this literally there's not there's one
called the body groom by norelco there's
beads not great I've tried it it's not
that great but there is something called
manscape to manscape is redesigned the
electric trimmer their invention is
called the lawn mower 2.0 with
proprietary skin-safe technology okay it
is small not saying you are but it is
small easy to hold and designed to get
in all your nooks and crannies without
snagging your sack I'm telling you it's
very important you want to stay hygienic
down there you want to stay fresh this
is a way to do it buy this buy this
product if you like my show and you want
to have a nice dick if you liked the
show and you want to have a immaculate
area around your penis this is the
product to do it I'm telling you okay
we've got a lot of things not only the
lawnmower 2.0 they've got the prop the
crop preserver and
tie chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer a ball deodorant and
moisturizer the balls are the new dick
that's what it's coming down to the
balls are the new dick where's your sack
at is it moisturize is it hydrated
does it smell nice balls of the new dick
I should really copyright that I want
shirts with that that's reality
we're heading into 2020 pretty soon the
dick forget it it's over patriarchal
assaults people okay looks like a weapon
not all of them but that's not the type
of tool we need in a more enlightened
era we need the balls and you need to
take care of your balls you're gonna
have sex with women with your balls
pretty soon not your dick not
penetrating in and out in and out
no balls only lots of girls out there
gonna be like I'm a Bulls only girl and
you can be like thank god you're evolved
and enlightened and just for you my
balls smell great and they're trimmed
get 20% off and free shipping with the
code Tim at manscaped comm that's 20%
off with Free Shipping at manscaped comm
use code Tim this is literally a product
that you need if you are sexually active
which I imagine six to eight percent of
my audience is the rest of you you got
to invest in yourself a little bit but
for that crew that's having sex somewhat
regularly especially if you're a man but
if you're a woman that identifies is a
man get this if you're
binary get this doesn't matter if you're
a non-binary lesbian get this if you're
a gay man who identifies as a a gender
like what are those jelica sir
by this it's fine if you're man who
identifies as a woman get this all of it
it's all under the umbrella of buy the
product every gender needs the product
because it's fur everywhere on everybody
and it needs to go maybe take it down
maybe just take a little off maybe you
want a little buzz cut down a maybe you
want the full Epstein just bare skin I
don't know I can't tell you what to do
but you need the product I use it a lot
of people I know use it if you do not
like it it is horrific to chase Peschel
e if you have to shave your balls
quickly like you're in a rush and you're
like [ __ ] I just have to shave my balls
before I go out to this topless place
just in case things work out okay get
20% off free shipping with the code Tim
manscaped calm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape calm and use code
TI m it helps the show it helps you your
balls will never look better and it's
very exciting thank you there'll be a
moment this profound is so profound
whole episodes very profound I just hope
it's reaching people that it can help
and if this did help you please tell me
and you know
especially if you're kidding like a high
school kid or college kid it would be
really it would be great to me I don't
know that I reached many young people
I was recently in Raleigh and my friends
like I bet a bunch of college kids to
come out I said I bet they won't my
audience are people like myself that are
shot um you know yeah it's the way it is
I'm connecting with people who not only
feel like the end is coming but welcome
it with open arms
they they welcome the end of this human
experiment like a puppy Christmas now
there'll be a moment when you go is
Thanksgiving Eve you'll come back from
college maybe you'll go to college or
maybe like me you'll be a man and we'll
sell I was a mortgage man you'll you'll
come back Thanksgiving Eve and maybe it
doesn't happen the first year but
usually it's not too soon after that
it's the second year you'll be standing
there and it'll be Thanksgiving Eve and
you'll realize that something's off
something is wrong something doesn't
make any sense
and it's nothing that you're doing and
it's nothing that anyone else is doing
the reality is it's like the that shitty
movie see the king made the Langille
years and it was a TV movie they keep
they go through some time warp and they
land in like LA but it's like a few
minutes before when it's supposed to be
and everything looks the same except
nothing as an echo and the food tastes
weird and it's like it's the same but
different and they realize that the
thing that explains that it's time time
is profound time moves things so you'll
be some bar and you'll be looking at all
these people and you'll go oh [ __ ] I'm
not supposed to be here anymore I'm in
the wrong time I'm in the wrong
dimension whatever like Jesse Reed's got
me talking about dimensions but you'll
realize that and then it will be time to
move on will be time to move on and get
a new group of people and this is what
happens and this probably happened
throughout your life to an extent until
you find people you really love and
appreciate you know until you find your
close family your friends your business
people the people that whatever until
you find them you're gonna keep having
that
when you look at a group of people and
go [ __ ] I'm done if you're going
somewhere there's some people that have
the same friends for their entire life
the same four or five friends that's
very charming that's not going to be the
experience of anybody that wants to
truly make anything happen
if you truly make anything happen you're
gonna have this time and it's
Thanksgiving you use a great way to
explain it but it'll happen over and
over again when you look at a group of
people that you were enamored with you
love and but no longer really excite you
and you're no longer excited to be where
you are and then you have to pick
yourself up and go somewhere else I
can't tell you when that's gonna be
but if you ignore that feeling if you
stuff it down if you shove it down and
you stay you become a loser that's how
you become a loser that's how you become
a failure okay and that's the reality so
when you have that excited feeling about
something you're doing with the people
you're with you're moving in the right
direction when you look at everyone else
you know they're not doing anything
wrong and I'm not doing anything wrong
and but it's just not working anymore
and that excitement and that energy has
died you have to you know Kelly Cutrone
just whatever she was she was on the
hills at dumb-show she was a fashion PR
in New York City forget her the point is
she had some some [ __ ] quote that I'm
sure she stole from someone but she said
if you're the New York if you're the
coolest person at the party it's time to
leave I believe that to be the case I'd
rather be the loser at a table of people
that have a lot more than me that those
are the people gonna learn from that's
what's going to be interesting if you're
the coolest person if you're the most
accomplished person you try to get to
that other table where there are people
because that's what makes life exciting
you know and it starts in high school
and many of you like I said man you're
the damned and I'll quote this canon
people go can you go through a podcast
without quote no you shut up I like this
quote okay I don't know where it's from
it's from a play but I don't know what
they're referencing I think it's Greek
mythology many of you
if you stuff that feeling down that you
shouldn't be somewhere and you stay you
will become like one of these people
wandering the earth not able to get into
heaven or hell awaiting the ferryman to
take you to where you need to go and if
you answer that call and you know what
you're doing and you feel like you're
always ready to conquer the next thing
[ __ ] you might be Donald Trump Tim de
la comédie calm for dates Tim Jay Dylan
di llo in on Twitter and Instagram
please follow us there please subscribe
to the podcast rate review share the
clips on Instagram and Twitter and
everything Facebook's at graveyard but
whatever we need some boomers Devin
where can they find you youtube.com
slash Devin Kosta dvan cos da podcast on
Apple podcast hey Thea love it with
Devin Costa and the Sebastian he looks
out and he just [ __ ] takes the mic he
wraps it around his head like he's
hanging himself and he goes hey I'm
doing an Epstein you guys all know
Epstein cuz you're all on his plane
[ __ ] tags you all fought kids and
then he drops the mic and he walks out
cuz [ __ ] those people yeah